hi everybody uh everybody who's watching
uh live uh a live podcast something that
i um
want to be doing a little bit more uh my
good friend here who i'm gonna let
introduce himself to the vayner nation
in a second and i
we're trying to get together in person
unfortunately i got caught up with some
travel and so
we're doing this remote even though
we're both i think in the same city of
new york right now but i'll be heading
out shortly
but um you know as i as i
started getting into the nft scene
more outwardly in 2021
when i was kind of doing my homework in
the late parts of
um of 20 and really q1 of 2021
one of my favorite artists aesthetically
subjectively and i think art is
definitely the eye of the beholder but
for me
um i just really enjoyed this
work from this artist and then when we
got connected and
i saw the sweetness and and just
genuineness of
his humanity um i knew that we would
interact for a long long time and
we've both been very very very busy
since
uh our first kind of interactions
earlier this year but
i'm excited to introduce someone to all
of you who are listening right now
and we're uh we're gonna chop it up and
i know he's got some stuff brewing so i
want to give a little exposure to that
and then
really just try to inspire uh and
educate people on what's going on in
this space because i think there's a lot
of
uh a lot of you out there that have the
potential for
a version of this story and that's why
it's important to me so
it just uh how are you my friend oh i'm
doing great this is really surreal
i'ma be honest gary i grew up watching
your videos and being a major fan
and to go from seeing you on twitter
interact with the space
into having a first call with you to
being here this is beautiful and i'm so
darn happy to be here
thank you why don't you tell everybody
who you are your name where you're from
and why don't you take the floor for
three four minutes and tell everybody
your artistic and nft journey okay cool
so i'm victor my artist's name is
ferocious i make nfts i
do art animate the art it's super
abstract
poppy colorful primary color surreal art
and i started with the little website in
my family home
i had my phone i would take pictures of
my art make prints of it
i bought a printer would cut the cut the
art
and sell it for like 20 bucks five bucks
do commissions for 10 bucks
and do that every day until one day
someone bought a painting that i did for
ninety dollars
and i was losing my mind never sold art
for that much oh my god ninety dollars
and he sends me an email saying
oh my god your work is amazing i love
the painting i have
i'd like more however i'm not interested
in physical ownership i want digital
ownership
and he sent me a link to super rare a
link to nifty gateway
all the nft platforms and told me to
apply
and so i did and ever since then when
was that victor
that was last year in march
so march of 2020 you become aware
more of digital art and immediately nfts
at the same time or a little bit digital
art and then slowly but surely
this concept about fts um
i was doing digital art before just on
my ipad but i wasn't
there was i didn't know about the
concept of nfts it was just oh the only
way you can own it is if you make a
print of it or something correct
and and how quickly
did you did you go down the rabbit hole
of nfts when this
person reached out to you and said i
want to do digital like that blow your
mind you're like wait a minute that's so
easy that's easier i don't have to cut i
don't have to ship
like did it resonate immediately well
immediately i thought it was a scam
i thought i thought because i'm a little
kid i
didn't have family i could really ask
for help so i thought is he trying to
steal the ip
is he going to buy like my characters
and go make a tv show or sell shirts
i don't know i see so i was hesitant at
first but you go on twitter and
immediately
one second my friend back to scams and
bad situations okay
in the facebook group oh what's that
dust oh it does all right
did you what dust were you talking about
the facebook comment
the fake [ __ ] yeah yeah it's just so
terrible
there's somebody fake in facebook saying
that i will never give free
anything like i will never ask you for
your aetherium
like you know uh
it's just it's unbelievable anyway spam
everywhere on live right now
podcast listeners sorry to interrupt the
show there's some you know fake accounts
trying to scam people never give your
seed phrase
and now your secret freeze to your
metamask anyway nonetheless so at first
that was very funny timing at first you
were concerned about that then what
happens
uh after i thought it was a scam yeah
like did you
do some more homework did you join some
discord did you go on twitter
what got you over the hump it was
googling what's an nft
and super rare had a newsletter where
they explained
everything broke it down did the mona
lisa original painting
analogy and that really made it click
and then going on super rare and
scrolling and seeing
all the artists sell the work and see
how much i was like whoa these are real
people
and that's when i was like okay this is
something but the world doesn't know
about it yet
did um when when okay so ninety dollars
physical blows your mind
what becomes the next blow my mind
moment what's the first
nft you sold for at what number
that really got you going like whoa i
mean the first nft i ever sold was for a
thousand five hundred dollars to that
person
uh to someone else actually interesting
yeah so you
tell me that story in detail because
again if you
just what you know victor what i want is
a
everybody in the vayner nation to know
who you are because i think you're worth
knowing
b for this podcast
to spur three more vocabuses
right because we are living in an
incredible moment
for artists where
this 20-year run of do stuff on the
internet for exposure and then other
things can happen
it's starting to shift before our eyes
and people are actually able to
sell things in digital form and it's
very special and so i want people to
hear
in detail which is why i agree to do
this podcast
so you is this the first thing you made
in nft forum
so first thing you sold so when i first
joined
this platform i was minting art for
weeks i received advice to men every
week
okay because every day is too much so
wait do once a week so i did that
and no one was bidding i'd get like 20
bids
but these were these were not so this
these were
offers only coming in it wasn't an
auction it wasn't a buy it now
you'd put it up and you would get quote
unquote offers
yeah so on super air there's an option
to list or there's an option just to
hold until you want to accept
now there's a timer where you can make
it a structured auction
but when i joined it's just you accept
when you want
or before they withdraw their bid yep so
i waited weeks minting once a week and
getting bids but nothing substantial
and then one day someone working at
super air said i think you should list
you would make a good first sale and
it's a larger amount so
i don't know if you there's no harm
really in
listing it so i listed my first piece
for 4.5 ethereum which at the time was a
thousand five hundred dollars
and did what gave you at this point
you were aware that some art was going
for real money so you were like
because right because you j don't forget
when was this by the way
right now we're june 2020 right so
you know only us only 10 weeks earlier
you're freaking out at 90
on paper but through this education
discovering this world
you're saying [ __ ] it i want a thousand
for digital
you thought there was a chance let's see
what happens
yeah i received guidance saying that
these 100 bids will look like a lot
but i learned about crypto i didn't know
about crypto
and i learned about what wales are and i
was like oh okay
i can list it for a little bit higher
and that's just what this market is it's
not college kids it's
these people who know how to trade
crypto and know all that world
so it's something different so i felt
fine doing that
but i didn't think it would happen i was
like okay
give me this advice let's see and the
next day after i listed it it sold for a
thousand five hundred
and i went on twitter and i was like oh
my god
i'm so excited and i did this whole
twitter spammed twitter
just saying my thankfulness yeah and i
took screenshots
not in a annoying way just in a i can't
believe this happened
and i guess the community saw that oh
this kid just
what just sold the piece who is this kid
i've never even seen the art
and then other collectors saw my
excitement and me yelling and went on my
super air and because i've been minting
for weeks
i had all this work that i haven't sold
so in the same day i sold the one piece
for a thousand five hundred
and then two other pieces for like two
thousand dollars
crazy how did you go to sleep that night
oh i don't think i did honestly i think
i just
drew and then went to school the next
day and was like what just happened
right because what you're a junior or
senior in high school at this point i
was a senior in high school and it was
like a week before kobit lockdown
unbelievable and did you like tell
anybody do you have like a best friend
that you're like yo you'll never believe
this [ __ ] i made 5 000
last night or were you almost weirded
out by it like
how did it go down this one girl in my
class tapped my shoulder and said
what are nfts and i was like
non-fungible tokens
and she said never mind and that was the
extent
to my discussion about it
what happens next what happens next
in your life what happens where does the
story go from there what when is it what
ends up happening after that
um after that i meant it again
i waited two weeks i think to mint and
then after that
i did a physical painting and then i
took a picture of it and animated the
picture
and i minted that picture and whoever
bought the nft
also got the physical painting and
it catched this collector's eye and he
said well i've never seen that before
i want that but i also want two more
nfts
so again i sold three nfts in like a day
and everyone saw that and was like whoa
who is this kid
selling all this art right now and it
built more hype i guess
and then what happened and then what
happened how much did that go for
the piece of the three i think it was
at the time twelve thousand dollars
fifteen thousand
so i mean this is like your [ __ ] life
is out of control at this point right
oh definitely it's the most money i've
ever seen in my life and my goal was to
move out i was in a really toxic
abusive home where i'd get yelled at
every day my family hated my art said i
could never do anything with it
and to make that much money and see that
i could move out and leave this
abusive household changed my life i felt
so free
i felt so happy and you know it's a
realization that oh my god my dreams are
coming true right now
did you take the ethereum and convert it
to us dollars you must have because you
needed it right
well i wasn't 18 and my family wouldn't
help me
so all of it was stuck in ethereum
because i had there's no
i tried every platform everything but i
was
[ __ ] right so it was all stuck in
ethereum and you didn't help me
and you didn't want them to know right
yeah no way
no one could know right so you're [ __ ]
so [ __ ] this goes down
like your life to your point it just
happened your life
dreams came true through nft and twitter
really which
created some buzz right covet hits
so now you're in this abusive home that
you're you hate and now you're probably
stuck there
more parts of the day school and
whatever probably used to be an escapism
you're sitting on all this eat
but you can't get it and when did you
turn 18
i turned 18 january 1st like
so you had to so you're you're sitting
for like you're like [ __ ] i have to wait
eight months
you have no idea how ethereum is going
to go up or down you're not sure about
that that's all new [ __ ] to you
and you're just literally going through
covid life changing
and you're counting down to january yes
exactly
wow that's insane bro
yeah it's all very surreal so funny lee
just said in the comments i was
and dustin picked up but i was literally
gonna say the same thing it's like a
[ __ ] movie
it's literally like a [ __ ] movie so
what happens you're you keep the
momentum going through
the summer and fall and winter yeah i
just keep doing what i'm doing
nifty gateway in like november there was
the picasso's bull sold for 55
000 and that was the record sale
everyone was like oh my god 55 000
and i saw that and i said whoa that's a
lot of money whoa
what is nifty and that's when they kind
of excelled as a new platform that
everyone was talking about
and i tech you can't do this now but i
just dm them i said hey can i
be on please and they said sure
so i had my first nifty gateway drop and
um that was just accessing a whole other
part of this community
that was i think also november last year
october last year from that november
that's right october november
and how does that go down it went
amazing
uh everything sold out i got to sell to
more
uh people yeah more people and just grew
my collector base it was amazing
how how financially well did that
project do i don't remember how much i
made
oh actually i do i still i sold my first
one of one
for 25 000 just one one of one for 25k
and i was like whoa i this is the most
i've made for one
thing i'm used to like bundle sales or
like
little editions but one piece for 25 000
i couldn't believe it and i think other
people saw that too
and were like oh this is really
something this isn't just some kid
like running around being crazy it's
something
it's fantastic so what's happening
you're going through the holidays
when do you notice that what what were
the moments that made you say
nft because you knew this was this
underground thing
did you think it might just go away
quickly that it was a very quick little
burst
a little fat quick fad did you like were
you
how are you feeling about it let's say
now wait september comes
are you just now done with school and
you're not going to college you're just
going to do this thing and like
have it how did september come at you
because you said you were a senior
back in march that means you graduated
oh wait i went from junior to senior
sorry god
i'm sorry got it so you're still i mean
are you did you just finish high school
uh high school ended like two months ago
so you you graduated high school two
months ago
yeah amazing so you
got it so you september you go back to
whatever so when does it start feeling
like
nfts are going more broad for you
when did that first hit the scene
january february of this year
um honestly i do think it was when
picasso's bulls sold
for fifty five thousand dollars because
just seeing other media discuss it
seeing
royalties seeing other people i had a
lot of mentors in this space that are
older
that were in nfts before these platforms
existed hearing them like preach to me
their ideas
i don't know i always knew it was
something but when that sold for
for fifty five thousand dollars i said
okay i'm in this
i'm in it and by the way uh uh
for everybody who's in live chat right
now uh
please let's i see a lot of you know who
ferocious is and
a lot of people are curious for the
people that know please
share some links in your chats on twitch
youtube instagram facebook twitter
of his work because people are jonesing
and we're not gonna there you go dustin
jumping on board
um so
so when does it go to
the next level so now you've hit this
crazy level
let you know call it a hundred thousand
dollars two hundred thousand dollars
levels that you could have never
imagined
and then and then ethereum starts going
up you're still sitting on that ethereum
so your money's compounding
when does the next level hit for you
and the space the next level for me was
my birthday january 1st this year
um i had another it was my second nifty
gateway drop
and the total was 340k
and it sold everything sold out in like
five seconds
and we like broke the website and
i was like oh my god i made this in like
five seconds what just happened
everyone in the community was so loving
and it was
stunning to me because do you feel that
you were adopted
by the whales and collectors of the nft
movement
i feel like i was adopted by the whole
space absolutely because
at a time where i was in such a bad home
where i had no one i could go to for
help
i could go to older artists i could go
to collectors and
ask them for advice on anything about
like doing my laundry to
what is ethereum how long should i hold
do i sell what
what is bitcoin all these different
things
how do you explain what an nft is in
your day-to-day
if a cousin or a friend of a friend or
just somebody
on the street like how do you explain it
not when you're in miami in the whole
like taking photos and everybody knows i
mean like
you know i don't know you well enough
and obviously if you have toxic home
you know your circle's probably small
but you know when you describe or if
this was
national television and you got to
explain it how do you go about it
um i explained it one time to my friend
just saying
it's not the most accurate way but i
just say
there is no accurate way this is why i'm
asking you it's your way which is what
i'm just curious about
i just say like you see a one-of-one
painting in the same way people love
that one-of-one painting and want to
keep it safe and special and they're so
proud to say that it's the real one
um and there's fakes out there but
there's authenticators to see that
there's the real one of one painting
i just say that i make nfts which are
the digital version of that
do you um okay so then
your birthday 304 now you're like
[ __ ]
super rich in your mind right like and
so
how do you handle all that and then and
then
next for you or for the space obviously
i think we're getting to the point where
people's
craziness starts kicking in but um you
know
and then characters like me and cuban
are showing up on tv like
take us to q1 of this year you had the
birthday thing
what happens next so next
i had my i did a drop with a musician
named two feet
and he did music and i did art and now
you see a lot of musicians in the space
but at the time it's like whoa a
platinum recording artist is in the
space
and cares and wants to learn about it
what
and we did that drop and made a million
like 1.1 million dollars
and we were the third drop on nifty ever
to make a million
ever and everyone was like whoa someone
else crossed over the million dollar
threshold what's going on
and more people were talking about nfts
there was articles written about it
because he's a musician
and that was the next whoa moment
and then and then i had as you know my
artifact shoe drop
so i worked with the artifact guys i was
talking to them way back when
but finally we sat down got shoe designs
talked about life talked about
philosophy and i drew these drawings for
the shoes he set it up for nifty put it
out and it made
three million dollars in seven minutes
and that was crazy that was
i've lost my mind i've never done a real
article before where someone like knew
about me and was asking me questions
and it was crazy to google for washes
and see like artifact shoe artifact
shoes see it on the news
see people talking about my shoes saying
what is this
what are you passionate about so what
about now like where's your mindset
what do you think about the space what
do you think about yourself what are you
trying to accomplish
give us a little the you know of the
moment now
right now i see the space that's still
new
i see this space as something that has
so much potential in every aspect i mean
owning digital assets
is the future the future is digital and
i think victor do you think it's you
know it's funny the way you're talking
is so matter-of-fact whereas everyone
else is trying to convince
i feel like you live in it
and i guess my question is given that
you're so young
do you feel like in a world where you
watch your classmates
never hesitate to spend money on
digital assets like power ups in madden
or
2k or fortnite or roblox do you feel
like you have that advantage let's say
over the cliche
40 year old who you know your whole your
whole
ecosystem of your contemporaries whether
they were your friends or not
you knew what was going on in your world
you feel like
because the under 18 crowd
has so often paid for things that are
just digital and coming to school
flexing that you had a fortnight
skin that cost money or a madden card
you feel like
just because it's always been there it
almost feels like nfts are completely
normal
and that for people of a different
generation they don't have that
advantage
similar to like for a lot of people that
are 30 and 40
having a cell phone feels very normal
but for their 60 year old parent
it didn't do you think it's a
generational thing to why you're so
matter of fact
of it like how why it's just so
uncomfortably obvious
oh absolutely i mean when i was born
there was like a playstation 2 in the
house like
i was so used to playing video games all
the time so i didn't understand ethereum
when i got in but it's like oh
digital okay i play video games i know
video game money i know
i know this so it was really easy for me
to accept and to just
take it for what it is and keep going um
yeah i think so completely do you
understand why people struggle with it
oh definitely yeah and i think that's
why
it's important like for my christie's
drop there are physical paintings
and i know some people are mad about
physicals they say oh
nfts and physicals shouldn't exist
together
i think they'll both coexist people will
always like physicals i think
like this yeah i mean i'm so fascinated
by people's need for ore in a world
where the world lives on and it's really
quite sad actually people live
in a need to convince or have it their
way
and and just have this great belief in
or
this is dead or this my way not that way
and the reality is
it's always going to be both it's just
like this interview right now
right we've all normalized video
conferencing and that's awesome
and that comes in handy for example
i would usually do all my podcast guests
in real per real life
right and we i had a scheduling issue
and what we wanted to do thursday i
couldn't make
and then i leave tonight and like we
just wouldn't have done this
but we're giving the exact content
that's needed but we still are thrilled
to do this in person in six months if we
have something else to talk about yeah
it's both i couldn't agree with you more
people ask me about sports cards oh gary
you're so intent of tease
i'm like i'm i'm about to buy an ungodly
amount of sports cards
in chicago in a month at the national
it's always going to be both
it is both now in our society we flirt
in the digital we flirt in real life we
order food at a restaurant we order food
in the digital we
watch a sporting event in real life we
watch it i mean
it's always going to be both i agree
what uh why don't you tell everybody
about the christie's things because that
must
i mean you probably a year ago thought
when you're 90
you might have something at christie's
and now you're here
oh yeah i thought
i thought living off art i'd have to
wait till 40 and then
maybe die and then get in christie's or
something
so to be the youngest artist at
christie's is insane
especially for the content matter for
this story is me coming out as
transgender this story is me talking
about my
piece of family in the most raw way
like i was worried i would send the art
to christie's and they'd be like you
know what this is too sad
or something but no they let me say my
story they let me have this platform and
talk to
the world and i think it's important too
that there are the physical paintings
because
it has catched attention for traditional
collector eyes
maybe they don't know about nfts but
they're like oh a painting
oh you have to get the nft what i don't
really know what it means but i'm gonna
learn more because i like the art so
much
and that makes me excited dust if you
can put the art back
up victor if you could speak to the art
a little bit because i think people will
enjoy that now obviously it's a podcast
that a lot of people are listening to
so we'll talk it through but obviously
the ones who joined us on the live
stream as i decided to do this as a live
one uh you're getting a little more of
the visuals
what uh what are we looking at or what
inspired it or
you know obviously i see year one age 14
it hurts to hide
is that is 14 when you kind of knew you
had different feelings
yeah 14 is when i really started to
question who i was
and realize because i grew up in such a
bad home i didn't realize it was bad
until i got older and was on the
internet and reading people say
that these things were bad that i
thought were normal what did you give us
give us an example if you don't mind to
share anything you're willing to share
i mean just like getting yelled at all
the time for everything getting hit
i'm like oh if you're loved everyone
gets hit and then i realized oh that's
bad not
everyone does get punched in the face or
something so
it's just stuff like that um where i
really started to realize that
i didn't like it there 14 because all
these nfts come
with archival doodles that i actually
drew at those ages
so 14 years old is also when i started
to
actually pour my feelings into art and
know that
it's all i had in life at that time
um maybe another piece that we could
speak to
so that's 14 what about what about
16 or just what about 16
uh when a child feels lost
so 16 uh
is when all of that pain of realizing
that life was hard
my family was mean to me being scared
because they said art
you couldn't pursue art 16 is when it
came down on me
and i became very suicidal i was in
therapy and my family said depression is
not real
after my therapist said that i might
have depression they pulled me out of
therapy
i had no help no teachers would help me
no one would help me
and this piece is me being a kid and not
knowing what life is and not really
wanting to be alive because i
i wanted a hug or something what about
friend groups
did you have a friend network uh no
growing up i didn't really have friends
i was really awkward so your social
awkwardness
kind of like you didn't play the part of
popular kid and you weren't able to find
others that maybe were you were just
within your own self huh
well because my family was so abusive i
had to go to court and then
move schools so i moved schools and i
lost the friends i did have
and i was just by myself every day
everyone already formed those
friendships they had so i would just sit
in a corner and draw
every day when did you know that you
were good at
art um it got to a point
of me drawing every day where kids were
like what are you doing
and they would walk by me and grab my
sketchbook and they would flip through
it
i was losing my mind i'm like oh my god
don't don't look don't look
but they'd be like wait this is good i
like this
right got it so even people that maybe
weren't necessarily
your friends were taking note and that
obviously carried a ton of weight
yes definitely what next
for you and the space
um i think because of the position i'm
in
uh i have means now to get like help
like if i want to do something gnarly if
i want to build a robot
it's something i think about a lot or if
i want to build something gnarly
or create a new metaverse kind of thing
or
whatever i have time right now where i
can sit
and think about what i want to do i can
have a team to help me i can
i don't know this space is so early and
i think sometimes people are
rushing to do stuff where i see it more
as
this is going to grow and this is going
to be insane and i want to put my heart
into something that i can really say is
what i want to say um so right now i'm
not sure i just
put my heart into the christie's project
so i'm trying to
take a step back and really analyze what
my life is right now
and what certain things mean to me what
um
what do you tell the the 14 15 and more
importantly
i would argue maybe even harder for the
49 year old
who's now long given up on their hope of
being an artist
instead of just a cliche you can do it
but like like is there any nuance
any kind of like second tier
for motivation whether it's practical
um uh you know questions
or um any kind of like
unique insight that you might be able to
share and then i'm going to
grab the five individuals that we have
quick questions from my befriends
discord to jump internet do a little q a
with you but
do you know anything anything stand out
to you because i think the two groups
that i'm most passionate about are
the 15 year olds who absolutely watch
a lot of my content i'm clearly gonna be
very inspired by your story but honestly
i believe that nfts have the potential
to do things for the 42 47 62 year old
that are remarkable and look you
in nft artland are gonna live one of
those one percent lives a mr beast the
logan paul
charlie demilia you're gonna but like
much like influencer marketing
i think that there's a lot of people
literally watching right now
and there's not that many people
watching literally people listening
right now and there's not that many
people listening when you compare it to
seven billion people on earth
and i think literally somebody who's
watching right now or listening right
now
even if this is two years from this
recording is a person that can actually
make
200 000 a year selling nfts who'd given
up on their creativity and decided to
become a professional doing something
they don't love at all
any any insights anything you can give
to those people i think
in the nft space there's a lot of like
anonymity and people like
that don't really want to share a lot or
like sometimes artists are so
in their zone working that they don't
realize what they're doing is really
cool
so in the nft space i think it's cool to
share what you're doing like take a
picture of your workspace and be like
this is what i'm doing
it doesn't even have to be done yeah
document because collectors or
other artists don't have concept they're
not you
so i think to provide perspective to
other people
really helps them learn more about you
and by proxy like
learn more about you and the art and
want to
pay more attention to what you're doing
because they can see more than just like
the one picture on their screen and i
think that's important do you think
andy warhol really figured that out many
generations ago
oh absolutely andy warhol was great at
that
um let's get into the q a dustin let's
bring some people in
chris how are you what's up gary what's
up ferocious
hi fire away my friend
all right can you guys hear me yes all
right um
so uh it's great to meet you first of
all like i i love your work
uh both of you guys in the nft and the
entrepreneurial world love it
i've been following you for a long time
gary you're you're kind of like a
long-distance mentor that you don't even
know you are and uh
and and it was just the story man like
it's it's a great story
like i props kudos to you man i wish the
best for you
and this journey you got going but i
guess i actually have a question that
you both could answer for being on
on the nft side uh where do you see the
market at in let's say the next five
years with nfts like
since we have the regulators and
everything coming into the crypto world
like where do you see the market now
like in the next five years from the uh
the artist standpoint side and
the the market trading side where do
what do you think and you can both
answer that
why don't you go victor and i'll jump in
after you um i think there will be a lot
more artists in the space
and i think it'll come down to just like
showing who you are more talking more i
mean youtube is full of all these
creators and then
there are these niches of people who do
different things so i think
people will find their way of community
in the five years
um i don't know you know for me i think
the first thing
victor said is exactly right i think
victor
i think the friends i think others
people and many others
do have a first mover advantage here i
do think supply
will outpace demand and i think that's
why i talk about 98
of nft projects maybe not being great
long-term investments
now it's because two percent is still
going to be
hundreds of artists thousands of artists
and
and hundreds and thousands of kind of
let's say collectibles maybe
the way i think about it right um but
but i do think that people have to be
very careful like
like to me what i'd like to think me and
victor represent
if i'm betting because i'm definitely
betting on myself and this is one of the
kids that i and i've been watching
that i think has a real shot at pulling
it off i think i think victor
and befriend's biggest vulnerability is
what amazon's biggest vulnerability was
in 2000.
amazon was destined to become the
greatest company in the world
amazon's stock was worthless in 2000
do i believe that there is a significant
chance
that v friends and ferocious art to be
less
valuable than it is on the open market
today i do
because i think things play out long and
i think there can be a dip
when let's say when there's just so much
and it's that moment in time i mean look
at the look at look at uh ethereum's
price
the davey friends launched it was 4 300
it's 1700 right now i mean
things are volatile it's early so you
know i'm always cautious to who's
listening
do i think nft is a big deal i think
it's the biggest deal since social media
i think it's here forever
do i do i think that 98
is dangerous investing i do do i think
you can be great at day trading if you
spend all your time on it
board ape you know excuse me
excuse me be friends the numbers are
staggering with the way people are
are flipping them right now um you know
art blocks
wicked craniums you know so rare even my
[ __ ] pickle if you bought it for
nothing like
you know like is a day trading right now
absolutely there was day trading in 2000
with internet stocks
but i think you have to be incredible
incredible
at um being thoughtful about a
knowing that this is very high risk so
you should be investing money you can
afford to lose
and b playing it in a 10-year window
instead of a 10-week
window like probably the far majority of
ferocious
art that i will buy in my life will
happen
on the next big carnage nft moment
where everything gets dragged down
because i think all of it if he does
what i think he does
and he stays this passionate and
creative and kid's talking about [ __ ]
building robots
if if he does what he is capable of in
22 years it works out and i think too
many people are thinking about
day by day yeah people are like day by
day
it's [ __ ] crazy to me well like if
you if you
let's say you're trying to do like a
five year plan and and you wanna you
want to uh
you should bet chris you should that i'm
sorry go ahead i'll let you push
okay and you want to uh uh
incorporate the crypto nft space um
how how how do you bet on that i mean
ready
very easily you put every dollar into it
that you can afford to go to zero
i got you and like what i'm talking
about is like real too high risk
otherwise you have to understand it
truly is it's too early
so you can only put money that can go to
zero okay
because if you if you need it and it
goes down by 90
and you needed it when you put it in and
you thought it was going to go up and it
goes down by nine and you need it
mortgage food life you're gonna get
[ __ ]
up good well what i'm looking at is like
real world like like incorporated into
like a real world business like um
um i don't really want to say too much
on here but like
well i mean like like okay that's
different that's called execution on
your end that you should do regardless
i got you you're looking at two people
that were
at different times you know victor a
year before you know nine months before
me
discovered it and [ __ ] did something
about it there you go and that's kind of
why
he started on my way we were on two very
different spectrums
he was a child and had
time i was in the prime of my career
with vaynermedia exploding and both of
us
stopped what we were doing from
different angles
so like the only way to like the
question of yours is [ __ ] action
mm-hmm i get that i get what you're
saying all right we got
we got to get to a bunch of questions
before we appreciate it guys good to
meet you thank you
oh my god eugene how are you hello
hi i'm so nervous it's unbelievable
good to see you hi gary you're uh you're
a bit of a hero
i started posting stuff online because
of you
and i've been a little successful in
tick tock because of you fiosh's
victor i s like a couple your paintings
uh really speak out to me it hurts the
hide really speaks out to me
and um now i can fly so the first one
the last one
really really spoke out to me and like
congratulations on all your success you
are a pretty awesome oh
eugene you're awesome thank you
i love you do you have a question
brother yeah i'm so nervous
uh so i'm a chef and i lost my job
during the pandemic and i pivoted to
digital
i teach cooking uh like kitchen trip
tricks
and like hacks and stuff so my question
is
um like i'm really good at the jab i
love giving stuff away so i give away
all my tricks
if anybody dm's me with any specific
question about food and cooking about
specific brands of like culinary stuff i
give him an honest
answer and my question is
like how how do you not feel guilty when
you do the right hook
and by by by believing in what you're
selling
okay um i mean like sort of the right
hook in terms of
maybe asking for help i'm really bad at
selling to be honest i'm like a really
bad salesman i get it
i get it some people are which is okay
yeah
so you could bring somebody in and share
in sales okay you know i'm
you know i hate asking believe it or not
i hate asking too
i just had a conversation with my
brother last week and be like you know i
hate raising capital but it's a real
thing and
you know maybe maybe you can play a role
in my world
you know i i think you know i i think
asking
i think it blows people's mind when they
hear that i'm i don't love it either i
really don't
i like when it comes to me which is why
i like retail
this is nine dollars and you just put on
a shelf and it's almost like not asking
yeah but um i think when someone is a
terrible salesperson
they should have someone do it for them
and give that person a commission
okay right like liter look start with
your family
then look at your friend group and see
if somebody wants to take 20
action by representing the sales engine
that's a good idea that's why i'm
garyvee
that's great this is my you know that
joke because that was [ __ ] ridiculous
is about is about you know this is my
domain this is business that part i'm
comfortable with
and that i know that's right that's
great yeah because
um i'm about to have a baby in september
and
this whole year uh i've just been
posting stuff without any
regard of trying to make any money but
like in the hopes that like later on i
could generate some revenue
and now i'm getting to be honest i'm
actually a little scared
because the baby is coming
and i'm gonna have to support you know
my family financially but i don't
want to stop giving the stuff away free
like creating the content for free
brother i'm giving
i'm i do it every [ __ ] day don't be
scared if you're if i'm hero
yours good news you're looking at the
[ __ ] poster child i give away 98
of the time and then you know once a
year a book or a sneaker
once every two years or 18 months like
you know
good news you kill you've built up a lot
of equity and
you're gonna you know i've got another
thing to tell you
there's another side to the selling when
you give a lot
i give a lot and it is stunning to me
how many people don't support me it's
one thing on v friends which was
expensive
there's people who i you know consume my
content
at scale idm with and they don't buy
three books when a book comes out for
15 bucks a piece so what ends up
happening is you realize
it's okay for me to ask and it's okay
for them even though i've given them a
ton of value for them to say no
i get mad at my friends who are like
[ __ ] i hate your style like i did it
for a year i asked
all these [ __ ] nobody bought they're
[ __ ] taking me for dinner i'm like no
no the market is the market
and and stop [ __ ] you know like
maybe that person doesn't have 45 right
now maybe they're faking it on instagram
and they don't even have 45 dollars to
their name so it's
ask without expectation give without
expectation and be okay if they do or
don't buy
okay okay just on that note i actually
did buy two year v
friends so well so that means we're both
doing well i'm really happy about
fun podcast fred what's good
hey hey garyvee how are you guys doing
we're doing well
what's cooking that's good man it's good
you know first off thank you for having
me on here and uh
vic you know congratulations on your
recent success as well thank you
definitely that's that's awesome good
story to hear there
um my question would be to kind of both
you guys
um you know i'm 29 years old i still
feel like i'm young you know i
i feel like i'm i can still take a lot
of risk in my life when it comes to a
lot of investments right now so
you know how do you determine you know
when to take
risk versus versus reward understood
victor how do you think about that
question i know he's asking the confines
of investing and maybe you haven't even
started that process
but there might be a different angle
you'll take on that question
you know and and and fred when you say
you know risk versus reward how go even
more literal on that because i think
it'll help people
yeah to kind of be more literal i mean
you know i i work 40 hours a week you
know any extra money i do i try to
invest you know hoping that it's gonna
you know turn into more money in the
future obviously
do you have a good sense that your
biggest asset is if you're only working
40 hours a week
how many hours in the week you have that
you're not working
does that run through your mind do you
realize that's your biggest asset
never really thought of it that way gary
i'm glad because
you know in a world where there's 168
hours in a week and you're only in for
40
and even if you go another eight hours
times seven which is a
nice chunk of sleep 56 you know at 96
you know hours between sleep and work
you you know you're still
looking at 72 hours in a week
and i think you know when i'm when i
hear you invest you know your resource
of time
is far greater than your resource of
that little extra money you have
from an investing standpoint and so
i'm really excited how quickly and kind
of concise you said i never thought of
that
that's your bigger asset to make money
to win
to be happy to be fulfilled
right like you probably saw it because a
lot of people saw it today
i was garage selling my ass off it was
my time
that i was willing to put into waking up
at six in the morning today
that led me to finding those 1000 magna
japanese comic book books it was my two
hundred seventy dollars
that's a seven thousand dollar profit
we're breaking it down right now
like there's seven thousand in profit
that's a lot better than two hundred
seventy dollar inve there's no there's
very few 270 dollar
investments you'll make that get you 7
000 in return
right but the asset i if i was still
22 what i would have done is i would
have listed every one of those
and put them on ebay and i wouldn't have
done them in bulk because i would want
to maximize my dollars
and i would have taken the next two
months probably another 200 hours
50 hours 30 hours i don't know what the
math would be there
to sell that it was my hours not my 270
dollars against what i bought today and
if everybody doesn't know what i'm
talking about it's all over my social
today
for everyone who's live if you're
listening on the podcast
it i you know there's a trash talk
episode coming about this
you know um there you go
right so notice what happened it's so
weird that you asked that question
literally today
literally seven you know 12 hours ago
i did what i want you to do which is my
270 dollars to buy those
you know thousand books that i found
today were far less
the asset that i deployed than my time
your biggest advantage right now is you
can learn you can network
you can do [ __ ]
oh yeah man that's people people like
gary my time is valuable like
the only people that tell me their time
is valuable is people who don't have
valuable time
victory your thoughts
i feel like what you said beats whatever
i gotta say
i don't have anything concrete i love
you brother all right let's move on to
the next one fred thank you
time time education networking
what's in your brain and whose soul you
connect with
these people right you're part of this
discord community
try to meet people try to do physical
like you know
get togethers like relationships
and education right everybody's think
people don't realize how much i
value education i don't like the way the
school system sells it
but education is all i know i got a a
one little drop of blood with nfts in
november december and i was like a shark
from 400 miles away
and [ __ ] did hundreds of hours of
research before i said a [ __ ] thing
so people that were ahead of me like not
only nine months ahead of me
like victor here when he saw somebody
that he knew and admired garyvee
came in and came in proper he's like my
guy instead of
right i mean i'm speaking a little bit
for you but i assume that when you saw
me come
and i'm actually talking knowledgeable
unlike what we saw from other people
from the left side
that made you feel good that made you
that reaffirmed you
your belief in me that built my
reputation to you
definitely fred learn [ __ ]
and meet people it's 40 hours a week
means you [ __ ]
at 29 you're [ __ ] loaded with the
greatest resource in the world
time awesome gary thank you oh i'll
gonna run with that for sure i love it
let's keep it moving
hey guys how are we doing what's good
i'm cooling man i got some questions for
you i've been making music and content
for six years
i'm actually just in the middle of a
skit right now i had to come in do this
but then back to work
um i love doing it i'm so happy this is
what i want to pursue in life
but my question is even after six years
of cooking up and i know both of you can
answer this
what do you do after you have like that
best song or that best
content or best piece of art and then
you wake up the next day and like
i got nothing like you you feel like
that was how are you going to beat that
how do you work with that
victor i'd love to hear your point of
view on that i think
you just keep trying and trying and keep
going and going and
don't sleep and then keep going and keep
going then get sleep and then let all
that process
and just keep doing your best you can't
really force anything but to an extent
you can't just
like sit around and wait for it to come
you got to make sure it happens
and um make sure people hear it
that's all yeah seriously benny for me
i've never ever thought that i put out
my best thing it's never run through my
mind
and i would argue that if you've
had that feeling the place i would ask
you to
go is that actually insecurity talking
and you're gassing yourself up
because i feel like probably deep deep
deep
you you know it's unlikely that you feel
that
you're there yet yeah you know what i
mean
yeah i don't know you so maybe you have
but like i feel like if you're
actually living that life where you
believe you just made the best [ __ ] ever
you'll never top it i think that
there's something there there i that
that has never crossed my mind
yeah go ahead i'd like to throw in
please
that i think i have made art that i
think is the best
okay i'm like oh this is the best pizza
i ever made
but use that as motivation where it's
like how can i make something
better yeah i don't think you should be
like nothing i make is good
i think you should look at it be like
that was fire how can i make something
more fire
and then be the artist scientist that
you are and keep
experimenting with that until you make
that thing that
you feel is right in your heart yeah and
i i totally agree with that because i'll
like i'll create an album
and each thing that i do that's after is
the best thing i've ever created so
everything that i'm doing since i'm
learning from my mistakes
is the best thing i've ever done you
know what you know go ahead i'm sorry
buddy no you're good go ahead
you know it's funny where you guys were
talking where i go
i just realized something for me it's
grounded in humility
i don't think i get to decide
i don't even have an opinion of the [ __ ]
i make
the market gets to decide yeah me saying
it's the best or the worst
is insular and delusional
you know so for me i haven't had
you know anything where all eight
billion people
said that's the greatest talk that's the
greatest clip of all time and until that
happens
i don't think i can even have the
audacity to be get to think it's the
best that i could ever
do but i have the audacity to think that
i can make something
that all 8 billion on earth say that's
it
thank you that that's that's amazing man
so it's
it's always been just keep going i've
always known just keep going because i
love what i do so i'm never going to
stop
but sometimes i'll wake up and the idea
that i
that i'm waiting for doesn't come to me
and so ferocious because you answered
that in the beginning which is great
and and many on that on that point
that's just a patience game
yeah you know when i hear you deliver
that sentence i'm like
that's why patient panda is my [ __ ]
guy yeah right that's why
i love patient panda and by the way i
also love patient panda because i like
everybody paying attention to patient
panda
and then i'm gonna hit him with patient
pig on the back end and stun everybody
and it was patient pig the whole time
like that's who i am
that's how i love to play but like you
know betty when you deliver that
sentence of like
impatience yeah and that branches right
into
okay that's why it's great to have so
many different aspects just like patient
pick and patient panda
all right this isn't working right now
let me go work on something else that i
love to do
and then you come back and you're
inspired or it leads to why
do you want the affirmation from the
outside
and it's not even the affirmation from
the outside it's like
i just want to do so i just want what's
next and my brain's like ah it's not
coming
but you know that's fair that's ambition
but when you balance ambition with
content
it gets real good like i'm hungry as
[ __ ]
you want to talk about a hungry
hammerhead i'm so hungry right now
it would blow people's if if we were
like all cut
and like our chemicals were like written
into words
people like this [ __ ] because i
know how people view me now
successfully they're like damn
he's [ __ ] hungry [ __ ] what it would
also say later in that sentence is
damn if nothing good happens to his
career ever again
he's smiling how the [ __ ] did he equally
balance
this level of hunger with this level of
being content
because you just love what you're doing
so much that it's like i'm gonna keep
doing it whatever i gotta do to keep
doing this
i'm gonna keep doing this and i'm still
hungry yeah i love that i love it it's
real
quiet hmm because you're you're
it's like i'm killed by myself i'm just
pla playing with
in my own world right like
so anyway there's break that down
hopefully that brings people
some value let's keep it going you got
you
last one hello hello
aidan hello what's up guys hey um
i'm super well very happy and uh
grateful to be here i've been following
you for a long time
i just want to say real quick it's super
funny that you brought up
uh patient pig because i'm the the holo
owner
no so it's pretty pretty destiny brother
that is that's what you're interested in
my friend
i know where you are bro you've got a
very good read of me i'm
very impressed i've got it as soon as it
looks
when when the project launched did you
realize that hollows were going to be
the best spectacular
or no i had a gut feeling at wood
only because of uh card collecting
and that element i thought hollow is
gonna out
shine right good for you man i cannot
believe you have that
i would argue that hollow graham
patient pig is
good [ __ ] brother it's a big one yeah i
am
very happy that vic stuck around for
this
uh because the question i was excited to
ask you but
uh i'm really excited to ask victor now
please um so i'm a very strong believer
that
adversity is the unlock to
really becoming your best right reaching
your best potential
as you can see you know i'm like
physically disabled i've faced
longest adversity in my life and it's
allowed me to
reach goals that i never thought
possible so my question is
what role do you feel adversity
has played in your mental framework
development
as well as your success i love that
victor please go first
that's a beautiful question um i think
now i don't get shy talking to anyone
because i'm like well when i was little
i was screamed out all day by my family
and they didn't accept me as my person
and my identity
and at this point i'm like shoo if i
grew up and had to deal with all this
from my own family
i don't care what anyone has to say to
me i'ma just live
and be me because i'm so tired of
growing up and
having to hide how i felt in my heart so
that's definitely
yeah adversity has made me who i am
honestly do you think
do you think your art would be as great
as it is without that adversity
um honestly no because i started making
art as an escape from the adversity so
art it's it's crazy how that all happens
in life
yeah you know listening to ferocious
story and aiden obviously
getting a sense again if you're
listening on the podcast aiden went on
screen and
aiden what what is your what is your
situation
i have a neuromuscular disease called
spinal muscular atrophy
and essentially your your muscles just
die over time
yeah so you know i'm fully capable
mentally and aware
i run my marketing agency i'm an
entrepreneur
i love biz dev that's why i follow you
of course
um so yeah yeah so when i when i you
know
it's it's incredibly uh clear to me
in my opinion of the situation of the
three of us
that i have the least adversity in my
youth of
us three but like what's probably going
through both of your minds
adversity is a very personal journey
and you know i always
i have a lot of people you know i have a
lot of people that i try to get out of
the reverse of what all three of us
emerged from our adversities
you know we had you know i think all
three of us there's two really two ways
to
you know respond to it and i think
they're both pretty extreme
it's it's a level of feeling
like a victim and just being really sad
about it
and there's a level of it being fuel and
you know for me i it's an incredible
driver
it's just an incredible driver um
you know growing up my whole life
and basically every adult around me
besides my mom
telling me that i wasn't winning because
i was so bad at school
um and not really having any place of
of you know that affirmation from like
what you were supposed to do
you know i think it's been really fun
for me to share my report card
occasionally because i think when people
hear that i say i'm a bad
student they see my level of success and
they think i'm saying c's
and like you know like mike you know
when you're a kid when you're 14 and a
grown-up teacher is telling you you're
going to be a loser when you grow up
like it it it lands
meaning like their words carry a lot
more weight
but it never really penetrated me and it
kept building and building and building
um and and for me i've you know you've
heard this for me because you follow me
like adversity is
the the foundation of success i really
believe that for
anybody who's had success i really
believe that you know i think it's
it's really hard to be hungry when
you're fed i think adversity
i actually believe aiden that's so much
of what
our society struggles with is the last
30 40 years
in modern american society we've tried
to eliminate adversity from our children
you know obviously not everybody you
know can't say that in front of victor
who's
has a different family experience but a
lot of
many millions of well-intending parents
have gotten very high on things like
eighth place trophies or going to school
and fighting for their kids and
really in my opinion creating a culture
that has created you know zoo animals
right
you know just not able to i say that
from the standpoint of not being able to
play in the wild
right there's a lot of people that hit
22 and
you know want their parents to continue
to be their financial and emotional
stability and it gets hard and
resentment starts kicking in and
so i just uh i feel like adversity
is such a gift i think accountability
is such a gift i uh i have really big
ambitions built around
adversity with my future i want to do a
lot of things like public speaking
and helping others and you know being a
figure
but before i do that i told myself i
would
build a successful company before going
that direction because i don't want
people to just
look at me and say oh this guy's in a
wheelchair he's inspirational
i wouldn't ever see what i've built i
think
i think it's i think it's a massive play
i think i think all of us
and when i say all of us the market
would have absolutely
accepted you as a motivation
as having such a severe outcome i don't
know
what's the math around your conditioning
do you know
um it varies i mean i'm pretty healthy
i have like no no i can breathe fine
no organ issues i mean just people live
in their
50s 60s 70s there's actually treatments
for my disease coming out
that is not really a cure but more of a
preventative thing it's awesome
uh i have i have very macro goals
brother like that's 10 20 years down the
road
um and i have a real big gut feeling
this last thing that you just said was
massive to me
what i was going to say before i kind of
sidetracked myself
is the world just just you being this
mindset
against your reality would have
landed with all of us the fact that you
took it to a totally different place and
said [ __ ] that
i'm gonna execute and you know it's why
i
you know this is where you know i
probably connect with you so much and
you with me
i i love being motivational
but i've run a company every day of my
life
since i was 22 i'm an operator i'm a
business builder
you know you know like i i when people
are like he's a motivational speaker i'm
like
running a 1500 person 300 million dollar
revenue business that i built from
[ __ ] scratch
after i built a huge business for my dad
while i did this
while i did resident while i did empathy
wines
while i did v friends while i wrote five
new york times best-selling books
and so you know and what's great about
that is
still fifty percent of the people ask
like what does garyvee do they just
think i'm on tick tock
you know and so like you know that uh
i'm
i admire that tremendously from you and
i'm looking forward to building our
relationship my man
love it appreciate it cheers laughter
awesome the other places
do you ever plan to build a refund
around adversity
you know what's funny about it now hey
i have i you know what's funny i have
such a big passion towards adversity
that
i you know my doodling you know
i'm i'm very inspired by ferocious like
my doodling is
not not confined just to my be
friends it'll be interesting to see
where i go with my stuff over time but
adversity is a very big theme for me and
yes i definitely have some thoughts all
right be thinking of me when you do it
and we'll talk soon cheers
um victor final thoughts
on a great podcast let's make sure
everybody's aware of what you got going
on
uh anything else you want them to know
and then parting shots
first of all i'm just really inspired by
what aiden said i'm like oh my god that
was so cool
that was awesome um but currently i'm in
the middle of a christie's auction i
just had a nifty
gateway launch like 30 minutes ago and
it went amazing and
honestly i'm just thankful to be here
and to talk to you gary again
you've been a huge inspiration and i'm
feeling very grateful for everyone
watching right now and listening
yeah i love you buddy everybody i hope
you guys enjoyed it
i hope everyone is super well uh
and we'll see you soon uh one last time
victor ferocious thank you so much
for your contributions i think this is
one of the best podcasts i've ever done
between our five guests even especially
you
i think i was in the right mindset i
just felt like it's a great show
beautiful thank you cheers cheers